[Music]
well it's something you normally don't
hear about every day
finding bones while digging in your
backyard a las vegas couple who lives
near thule springs and
floyd land park in the north part of the
valley discovered some questionable
bones while they're building a pool
now while the bones are believed to be
from an animal sally jaramillo joins us
live to explain what you're supposed to
do if you make a discovery like this in
your yard
sally denise with all the construction
happening in the valley
it's surprising we don't hear more about
these discoveries
from digging and excavating but the crew
digging this pool did all the right
things when they unearthed these bones
during the last ice ages this area was
covered in springs
joshua bondi is a director of research
at the nevada science center
he says tully springs captures a
prehistoric time with rocks and fossils
those animals were making their way
across the
mojave desert their shopping here is a
resting spot animals such as mammoths
camels bison horses american lions
matthew perkins was shocked after
receiving a call from the pool company
and police outside his home what's going
on with our pool what's going on with
our house
and he told us they found bones while
they were digging out the pool perkins
wondered if another prehistoric
discovery was made
what is this first because we don't want
to fill something in that might be worth
any
importance any significant scientific
values if you look behind me at the
at what they found during this
excavation is that we're in what's
called geologically the las vegas
formation
a body of rock which has been well
defined throughout the north portion of
the las vegas valley
these gravels represent more recent
deposits so within the last 9
000 years and if you come down to this
greenish layer it is about 14
000 years old bondi believes the bones
may be from a horse
as during the ice age two species of
horses were known in the area
this is the shoulder blade here going
back into the hill
this is the upper arm bone or the
humerus and then going back that way is
the forearm i feel like it is just a
matter of time that you're going to
start finding more and more things like
that that
will help scientists and the community
learn more about
the las vegas valley
if you live in aliante and or the
northwest your home is probably built on
the same rocks so if you come across
a suspicious thing like this you want to
make sure you call
authorities or a paleontologist
reporting live sally jaramillo
8 news now that's something you don't
see every day it's very cool